I feel that no aspect of MU2
is more interesting, and
potentially more impactful to
the management of chronic disease,
than the requirement that more than
5% of all unique patients seen
by an eligible provider during
each reporting period either View,
Download or Transmit to a third party
their digital health information.
This is referred to as VDT, and
ONC has related specific guidance,
as shown here, as to what electronic
patient summaries should be
made available to patients
under various care scenarios.
The first one listed here
is Transitions of Care.
This is, for example, when a patient
goes from a hospital to a nursing home
or back to their home from
either of those facilities.
Errors often occur at transition
points because information is not
passed on completely and accurately.
In lesson five,
we'll look in detail at the electronic
clinical summary specified
at transitions of care.
But you may wonder why providers
are measuring activities
usually done by their patients.
Research shows that patients are far
more likely to embrace electronic
self-care tools if their provider
encourages them to do it.
And even provide some
help in getting there.
As a result of VDT, many more
provider practices will be offering
encouragement and even the needed
tools integrated with their EHR.
We'll return to this and
to VDT in lesson seven,
when we discuss these
patient facing tools.
Later, you'll also obtain and
use Marla's clinical
summary in some activities.
Which of the following is a key new
goal of Stage 2 of Meaningful Use?